[Music]
it's great to be out campaigning again
local elections can be an important
yardstick to know how political parties
are doing more generally but this year
campaigners have missed out on vital
weeks of knocking on doors to persuade
voters to back them
because we've not been able to go door
knocking because of the lockdown we've
been
doing a lot more telephoning but of
course you don't have every voter's
telephone number
uh and a lot more online as well so
people may have seen things popping up
on
facebook and those are better than
nothing but really there's
nothing that can replace the personal
interaction
between a candidate and a voter you know
that's what tells the candidate what
really matters
and what they need to focus on those
last weeks have made it much harder for
politicians to know who
will cross which box on the day this is
the reality of campaigning in a pandemic
instead of working from a village hall
campaigners are working out of the backs
of cars the
leaflets are stacked up and handed out
and everything is socially distanced
the pandemic has been really
unpredictable and it's made these local
elections unpredictable too
it's obviously the beginning everyone
was slightly nervous about knocking on
doors not knowing how
everyone would feel but actually i think
everyone's quite keen to have a chat
the pandemic has seen communities come
together and those independent groups
have realized they can run things pretty
well themselves
now many are standing for office adding
another element of uncertainty for
established parties
we have seen a number of different
independent groups but we are seeing
those independent groups
popping up across the country and it
will make it more complicated because
as i say these are very local elections
it's down to ward and division
and you start to split votes in
different directions makes it really
really unpredictable
others are more positive about their
prospects but still conceived
campaigning this time around hasn't felt
the same
people are really pleased to see us i
think in some cases we may be the
first people they've seen uh this year
since uh
they last spoke to a delivery driver so
we're we we've made their life slightly
more interesting
and in terms of how you've been able to
run this campaign
i mean people who are involved in
politics will know that the big part of
campaigning is the social aspect and
you guys have lost that i mean how does
that feel this time well it would be
nice occasionally to get to the pub
after a canvassing session or indeed
even to go out and gaggle local
elections while not always the most
exciting political moment
are really important this time around
normal rules are out of the window and
campaigners are preparing for surprises
in a few weeks time
kate mccann sky news